bonjour j'ai un vestiaire merci de
répondre à nos questions première
question combien de temps ce
cessez-le-feu va-t-il durer
dieu seul le sait n'est ce pas c'est une
question très très difficile parce que à
un cessez le feu n'est pas un traité de
paix et encore moins un traité de paix
sociale ah parce que ce que l'on a vu
depuis quelques semaines au moyen-orient
à ce ne sont pas seulement des requêtes
mais c'est aussi une division à
l'intérieur de la société israélienne à
partir à de projet d'expulsion un de
jérusalem est à du fameux quartier de
cheikh jarrah et donc il faut regarder
non pas maintenant les missiles mais ce
qui va se passer dans les prochains
jours ou prochaines semaines ou
prochains mois autour de ce dossier là
et à l'intérieur d'israël
entre donc la population arabe et la
programmation israeli et qui sans
vainqueur de ce conflit armé d'une
dizaine de jours israël le hamas
benyamin nétanyahou et mahmoud abbas
à nouveau c'est quelque chose de délicat
à arbitrer à illies à ovnis militaire
donc de ce point de vue là israël sort
vainqueur à 80 90 % des roquettes et ont
été interceptées par le système dôme de
fer
ils ont infligé israël a infligé des
destructions de tout le réseau
souterrain du aaa masse donc des
capacités de fabrication de ces
roquettes a donc d'un point de vue
militaire israël mais d'un point de vue
politique à nouveau à il y à un point
d'interrogation car comme on vient de
l'évoquer
maintenant le débat va se trouver à
l'intérieur de la société israélienne
donc c'est le point que nous allons
avoir à suivre dans les prochaines
semaines et on voit benyamin nétanyahou
à vos côtés sur les images comment
expliquer que le premier ministre
israélien
fini par céder qu'est ce qui s'est passé
exactement il hier soir durant ce fameux
conseil de sécurité n'a pas fini par
céder je pense que là l'objectif était
de revenir à la situation antérieure et
arrêter le conflit à ce n'est pas dans
l'intérêt d'israël de poursuivre au delà
d'une certaine durée
ah les objectifs militaires ayant été
atteint s'il a un israël a détruit 60 70
80 % du réseau à 2 du métro comme il
l'appelle donc des tunnels à l'intérieur
de gaza
l'objectif militaire été atteint avec
l'élimination aussi un saut nombre de
leaders militaires du hamas
donc de ce point de vue là à la paix
c'est le feu par don pouvait être
acceptée et deuxièmement il s'agit pas
de maintenir avec une tension à
l'intérieur de la société israélienne
d'un point de vue diplomatique est ce
qu'il faut retenir de son auteur de
conflit avec les veto américain
multiples à l'onu la résolution
française qui n'a pas abouti
la médiation des gîtes également voilà
je crois que pour aboutir à un cessez le
feu il faut pouvoir parler avec tout le
monde et c'est ce que les égyptiens ont
pu faire ils ont un à un traité de paix
avec israël depuis 1977 1979
donc c'est une relation bien et abus de
confiance dans la dans la durée et donc
les égyptiens aussi sont bien sûr à même
de parler avec les palestiniens avec le
avec le hamas donc pour arriver à un
résultat de compromis il faut être
effectivement assis au milieu de tous
les partis est ce ce que l'egypte a bien
réussit à faire berlin appellent ce
matin à régler je cite les causes
profondes du conflit qu'est ce qu'il
faut entendre par là c'est quoi c'est
une solution à deux états par exemple
sachant qu'il ya d'autres d'autres
réactions à l'international via paris
également ce matin qui appelle à
relancer le processus politique
politique tout comme l'union européenne
effectivement bon la position aussi
américaine est une solution à deux états
et là on se heurte
à aux options du sionisme religieux à
l'intérieur d'israël à qui appelle au
grand qu israël mais comme le dit un
certain problème
haha trop embrasse mal étreint et donc
si la poursuite d annexion en
cisjordanie se poursuivaient si les
expulsions à l'intérieur d'israël se
poursuivaient là nous arriverions à des
tensions vraiment très très importants à
l'intérieur de la société israélienne
entre populations arabes les populations
à un israélite et donc là on aurait à
nouveau une situation difficilement
supportable à l'intérieur du pays donc
il faut que à nouveau à la société
israélienne fléchissent à son mouvement
futur il ya 26 ans maintenant ils savent
habits n'étaient pas des extrémistes
religieux
il faut faire un bilan c'est un six
dernières années
on sait qu'on y voie de la politique
intérieure le président israélien a
demandé aille ailleurs la pid l'opposant
de benyamin netanyahu de former un
gouvernement il ya eu quatre élections
législatives en deux ans en israël
que va-t-il se passer ces prochains
jours à ce que ça va être décisive pour
l'avenir et les prochaines semaines à un
gouvernement qui passe déneigement des
mets très délicats politique un griot
d'israël parce que un vétérinaire
l'homme un furet donc ils seront hors du
aura et un médecin étaient quelques
centaines dans l'incapacité de prouver
un gouvernement sans je me permette je
me permets de vous couper gérard vesper
parce que la qualité de transmission
n'est pas très bonne et merci en tous
les cas d'avoir répondu à nos questions
merci pour pour toutes ces précisions je
rappelle que vous êtes le directeur de
recherche à la fée mots la fondation
d'études pour le moyen-orient et
pardonnez nous pour pour cette saison
difficile